[Music]
all right in marketing mean news
submitted by nothing but Ford Ryan
Reynolds decides to hire the model from
the failed peloton what is - oh did you
hear about the belt again shows cons
Eli's not the ketchup Oh which I don't
have
is this like 30 to 60 second commercial
of like this woman who has the opening
she is surprised by her husband get
gifting her a very expensive stationary
bike that's by peloton we've seen a
million times like in between
commercials so it's worth like two
thousand two hundred and forty five
dollars and so this whole commercial
she's just like blogging her way through
it and saying at the end of it like oh
and at the end of it she's like sitting
her husband down to watch this year-long
flow I have seen that trying to work out
it was pretty funny it was bad so crazy
backlash on it cuz like when she was
vlogging like one of the things was if
you've been working out for a year how
come you look the same
she's already fit when she started and
the other one unless she was like I'm so
scared to try this bite like yeah like
she was about to give birth
yeah so people just say why are you
freaking out over us - good bike yeah
you make it seem like it's crazy that
that sucks how actors get to [ __ ] I
know they're just reading the script I
know people started associating this ad
with like misogyny and like pretty much
like kidnapping her like she's trapped
in this marriage because like she like
she looks like she's afraid in the ad to
get out um and then even the the husband
and the ad he only had like one line in
it and he started getting he started
being like the face of like an abusive
marriage
that is dangerous it was really bad Ryan
Reynolds hired I like Ryan on the
monstrous which her name is Monica Ruiz
[ __ ] Ruiz Ruiz
I couldn't even say that Louise Louise
and this is the ad for aviation gin it's
I think oh it's there what a good sport
she is what is it Aviation is really so
Jin she needs a drink
there's a new beginning
that's tie by the way
Oh caption that ad on Instagram with
exercise bike not included my riddles
has always been a cool guy like back
when he was in the movie waiting and he
did some national lampoon's he did one
of those movies when he was in college
it like that and to be one of the few
people who have ever done a Marvel and a
DC movie DC what he did he was a witch
green lanten yeah yeah so he's always
been super cool in my book man I float
around rebels that I did nothing for me
because I had no idea what that story
was or anything so I'm like like not
getting the joke I've been noticing that
like wait so you didn't never saw a
commercial I don't know who that woman
is I know the context of it so I didn't
get it and I've been noticing that more
lately is that since we are more like
this mean closer and if you miss one
then you miss the whole joke but noise
and that like if I watch like a twitch
stream and they talk about like some
terms like Oh pause pause you don't know
don't know what that is I still to this
day even though people will explain to
me in the twitch chat I'm like what is
pause there's two pugs that I know of
I don't know if it's an innocent pug I
don't know if you think about different
now she's thinking about pawg already P
og is once on that oh yeah the drink
passion orange guava which oh when I'm
with Hawaii we thought we were like
getting this like exotic fruit whatever
like what's this punk drink over here
and then she was like was like papaya
orange I just told you what I'm saying
she said that to us and we're like no no
no no like what was the POG and we
thought she was listing out other kinds
of fruits and we're like oh and she left
her like I think she means like though
that's what it is they say they say like
they say like booty white girl yeah but
once you want you to miss the mean with
like that it's like the language is this
like different like English doesn't even
work anymore
and stuff like that I'm like I don't
even know well yeah it's like part of
pop culture like I remember growing up I
loved watching like I love the 90s I
loved the 80s on each one and so that's
how I was actually I was able to learn a
lot of pop cultural references because
of that show [ __ ] love that show so
much but yeah there's like a lot of pop
culture like things that you just kind
of have to stay on top of especially now
with the Internet
like literally everything's at your
fingertips but that's what this
commercial so the aviation commercial is
pretty much painting the actress or like
the wife from the peloton commercial
yeah right after that commercial forest
band because she was an abusive
relationship that he was forcing her to
work out even though she was already
really skinny and so that's how they're
kind of painting it like she's there
with her girlfriends at the bar and it's
like you think now she's so [ __ ]
lucky imagine bombing like a nationwide
commercial in your life or a role yeah
and then finally your agent calls you
you're not gonna believe this you know
like what Ryan Reynolds wants you to be
the spokesperson because what they
should what they should have done for
Scarlett Johansson is put her on a
Japanese variety show and in shooting
and it taught her how to speak Japanese
she want to get it though yeah just
learning how to speak Japanese don't
take you a year that's true yeah so then
the
Monica she ends up just saying like how
thankful she is that she was able to
have the opportunity from peloton and
then also for aviation Jen because you
know for her she's just an actress like
she's just trying to make a living so
she was like [ __ ] yeah I booked two jobs
like two for one kind of companies don't
be knowing hotter every time yeah why
Israel man like even like sometimes the
people we advertise with a be singing
the scripts maybe like you're looking
horrible now you came to us because you
like the tone listen to this give us the
bullet points out the stuff we need to
say to sell your product but don't write
a script for us you don't know the tone
of my demographic and I can't go on or
like hey guys would you like to increase
your health and fitness I don't again
[ __ ] about that I have to work that in a
way that there's gonna relate to their
life
I think peloton is Miss a peloton misses
a mark put that type of [ __ ] so oh no I
think I think a lot of companies really
just me I'm gonna tell you what it is I
mean this is this exactly what it is
they don't have enough they don't have
enough people of color in these goddamn
boardrooms when they write new scripts
that's exactly what it is you need
somebody from each generation each
demographic or at least somebody that
connects with those demographics to help
with these scripts because they are
trash yeah they are you get people on
their team that can voice things like
they don't even listen conditional
people are just like that doesn't work
we've been doing it this way all this oh
my gosh I'll just say okay I'll wait oh
why gods and these boardrooms
think you know it all but you couldn't
have a [ __ ] clue more like every time
y'all try to do something that's uncool
remember when we were doing the
mannequin challenge and then all the old
white guys did it on it plain and you
see they own ass shaking cuz they took
the water pills and we're just like [ __ ]
it we don't want to do it anymore
[ __ ] deal on your penis water pills
be like I want to know whether they act
like blood thinners but they make you
pee more because they thin out to blood
oh I don't even know what that is oh oh
why made you ruin everything man yeah
y'all need to take influence from other
people that are younger and people of
color because we know I know is the ego
but it's costing you money I just say
yes to everything and then make him
think that they did it I don't [ __ ]
argue you don't give any pushback no I
this is I go yeah that's what's
happening good job and then I do what I
[ __ ] want and in there like oh yeah
and I'm like yeah that's that's that's
dope I was inspired by your script and I
did my own thing they they give me
pushback I I it's basically you got a
treat like a relationship right
you [ __ ] ghost them for three days
and then they come back and they'll just
they're like you know what I just want
you to post anything at this point
that's right [ __ ] now I'm starting to
think that the story you told us above
the guy approach to you as a male
prostitute may have had some holes in it
all right
the fact that you just say you just do
what they tell you where do you think I
learned myself no like I think in the
past I changed the way that I treated
brands because I used to fight about
everything and I used to like look at
the contract and be like nah this is
this and this but I've I forgot that
when when they're dealing with a lot of
other influencers and all that they're
unprofessional as [ __ ] yeah worse than
me yeah so me being on time and all that
[ __ ]
that's just my ass trying to I don't
know yeah and they rush you and do all
that stuff because you know they want to
look good and all that but at the end of
the day you're not dealing with another
business owner you're dealing with an
employee yes they don't give you honest
job you gotta remember that they don't
take this [ __ ] home part of that day I
don't give up lot
so you're the only one getting stressed
out that's true that's so that's a good
way of looking at it and I work with
them it's not like I it's so who's
giving you [ __ ] your boss okay so this
is what's happening all right cool no
worries what does he want
like what do you think they want oh they
just want to get good views or this and
I'm like all right cool
we'll make it work and I'm not doing
this [ __ ] but I don't talk to him like
that you know
like I think over the years I learned
how to just deal with it and man I'm not
even stressed out anymore that's good
yeah I need a because I always be
stressed out you got a finesse it man
you got a finesse it like it's it's it's
yeah just like if there's times when I
make complete mistakes like oh you even
say it that way or whatever and I'm like
oh man I can't record this I'm gonna be
gone for like a mom mmm but if you want
to video up now I get it up now and
they'll be like yeah we want it up now
that's cool yeah I mess up on my first
brandy oh because they were like Dave
your price and I was like okay and I
thought I'd like a fair price whatever
it I gave it to make me like all right
cool and I was like god damn it that
means they would have given me way more
if I would have just been like I'm
always whoever makes the first place
loses that's what I've always heard
whoever gives the first prize depends on
your strategy man cuz you can go it's
like if you want a long term with this
company hook em up and then they'll be
like man he's always easy to work with
that she does it for cheap and then so
it's like this it's like if you work
with this guy for a long term right
you could secure a whole years worth of
extra [ __ ] or you could just do one time
and you charge them a lot and I don't
really believe in charging too much
because you have a lot more pressure so
the more it is charged the more they're
gonna be like our budget is like you
know we're giving 50% of our budget to
you so a lot is on the line and I got
that relationship with Disney I know it
oh cool yeah and that's my thing is like
I rather secure years worth the [ __ ] the
year before and then just have them keep
coming back then you know like I have to
put everything aside cuz this deal is so
[ __ ] big but that's my strategy
though other thing that might have
worked but the video game that I was
doing a thing for they kind of like died
and their very early death and it's kind
of coming back now but it's like it died
very early so I was like you could work
if the video game did well now I'm like
I should have took it was gonna cast up
yeah well it's a balancing act
yeah
[Music]
you